only few companies are big enough to
supply the needs of an entire market
even the large ones must break down the
total demand into segments and choose
those that the company is best equipped
to handle market segmentation is
marketing strategy that involves
dividing a broad target market into
subsets of consumers who have common
needs once demand or characteristics
you'll be developing a marketing
strategy that targets the individuals in
your chosen segment you can learn the
basics of it in the book that became the
Bible for startups 25 years ago and is
still valid crossing the chasm by
Jeffrey Moore let's meet Jeffrey Moore
himself learn what he has to say about
market segmentation hi my name is
Jeffrey Moore I live in Silicon Valley
I'm a business author I am a member of a
venture capital firm and I consulted an
advice technology companies largely
entrepreneurs tend to have visions of
global domination and in that model you
want to segment the whole world
you know because eventually the whole
world is gonna buy your products just a
question of who's gonna buy it first so
I think the whole world thing is a great
you know sort of fantasy that keeps you
going at night and on the weekends but
eventually if you're gonna actually
light the fire you know when you light a
fire you don't want to run a match up
and down under a very big log right
you're gonna just burn your fingers what
you want to do when you light a fire is
you get some kindling and then you get
some crumpled up paper and you get a
match and you hold the match in one and
only one place until it starts to burst
into flame after then the flame can grow
but so the key thing with the
segmentation at the beginning for an
entrepreneur is where are you going to
hold the match and how long are you
gonna hold it in place until it's lights
and sometimes you put holding it in the
wrong place some place you're holding it
under a brick bricks do not burn right
okay so you got to move the match but I
mean but what you don't want to do is
just continually moving back and forth
and entrepreneurs who are in love with
their product have a very tough time
with this problem entrepreneurs who are
in love with their customer do not have
a tough time okay so how do we start
this fire let's explore the different
types of segmentation